alex cobb looking for his first
orioles win at camden yards with 16
consecutive home starts without a win
on the ground to third alberto a little
double clutch to second
and uria still with time to turn it five
four three martin perez takes the mound
he is four and five in his career
against the birds here's pat valleca he
has homered in
back-to-back games for the second time
in his career
the other way to right center field
that's well hit bradley to the wall
and it is off the top of the wall and
gone
make it three straight with a home run
for pat valencia
a little bit earlier tonight and the
orioles have their first
lead of the series how about pat valleco
five home runs now and 60 at bats this
year
perez says yes two strikes on mount
castle
and he got him 90 miles an hour to
strike him out first k
there for martine
there's verdugo laying into that one
into the gap that's going to keep on
going
all the way to the wall and alex verdugo
has himself a double for a 13-game
hitting streak oh he doesn't let him get
away with it get me over breaking balls
what he does
first pitch hacking
[Applause]
martinez sends one on the ground to
third alberto to
urea sends the inning cobb gets his man
out of the stretch here
and strands a pair martine perez back
out he faces ramona
here's a line drive base hit ramon
urrius
on the first pitch he sees of his first
major league start
urias picks up his first major league
hit
i love it be aggressive
and foul tipped and held by vasquez for
the strikeout
2-2 strike three swinging so he got
moreland to swing and miss
through all three of his pitches the
curveball to start then the fastball and
he finally finished him off with a good
splitter
here's the one two swing and a miss he
struck him out
on 3-2 severino is tied up 95 maybe a
little bit
off the corner but still a pretty
tantalizing location for perez
jackie bradley junior roll for one
to center field driving back mullins
still racing back
it is gone into the bullpen
smile jackie we were spelling a home run
really were yes we were and his first of
the season has tied the game
a searing shot that just got over that
fence in center field
there's another drive this one to left
center field that's well hit that's back
there
on to the warning track and that will
skip up over the wall for a double
so peraza is aboard the red sox are
threatening to take the lead
there's the drive that one driven to
right field a leaping effort over the
head of santander
here comes jose perazza in the score
and it's another double for verdugo
another
stinging line drive and the red sox take
a two to one lead
a lot of pitches to hit this inning and
they are not wasting them
into right field here's pillar to the
track of the wall leaps and slams into
the wall he
hangs out of the ball again he did it
again
he is something out there he has been
punishing walls for a couple of weeks
now and he's done it again
if you're mount castle you're thinking i
got my first big league hit and tipping
his helmet there
wow i mean that hit that's up man he has
it safely in six in a row
he'll serve that one for a base hit into
right
mitch moreland he's going to be heading
into third
and he advances to third base on the
base hit second of the night by
christian vasquez
a walk a base hit some nifty base
running and they're on it first and
third
pillar trying to make it three to one
it's softly runner trying to score the
lake up and over
save it for his base as the run comes in
and the red sox lead it three to one
pretty good pitch there he got mullins
with it he struck him out one away
swing and a miss he struck him out he
gets him in order
bogart strives one to center cedric
mullins
take that kevin pilar terrific play by
mullins keeps the score at 3-1
and lisantander is the man that you're
facing
want to make sure you do it right
16-game hitting streak coming into
tonight
that's crust down the left field line
from santander
into the corner it is fair
and gone he's done it
again anthony santander
unstoppable it's his world
and we're all just paying the rent
even i have allowed kids at first base
he's going swung down to miss throw down
here's the tag got him
cut him down christian vasquez to retire
the side
on the tag at second top of the 10th
inning 2020 baseball that means a runner
at second base to start the extra inning
it is alex for dugo
red sox with a man at every base mitch
moreland in a great spot
that is up high for ball four and that
will walk in to go ahead run
he's walked three consecutive batters
verdugo will score
and the sox lead it 4-3
bunt laid down beautifully moreland to
third
safe mitch moreland tried to go across
the way to third
and the orioles have the winning runs on
base with nobody out
that gets away that will tie the game
ruiz is in
from third and the winning ron mullins
motors to second
and the red sox are going to go five-man
infield two-man
outfield for pedro severino 2-2
in the air that will do it pedro
severito a walk-off winner on a saturday
night and the orioles snapped their
losing streak at
six five four in ten